Hi, I'm Mike Samuel.
I work on Google's security engineering team
where we try to improve programming languages,
libraries, frameworks and other parts of our
software development tool chain to make it
easier to secure robust software.
Practice of programming has some of the best
advice on how to avoid bugs in your software.
So, every bug you can find can teach you how
to prevent a similar bug from happening again,
or to recognize if it does.
And my colleagues and I put together a roadmap
for Node.js security.
We want to understand what are the kinds of
bugs that have security consequences in Node.js.
I'm not going to walk you through it.
I would like to show you a little bit about
how security engineers go about our work.
How we identify classes of vulnerabilities
and try to address them.
What I would like to impress upon you, given
the right tools, we can address entire classes
of vulnerabilities.
Instead of just finding a particular instance,
we want to deal with all instances of a bug
in a product.
So, I'm going to show you some mediocre code.
This is code that I've written.
And I'm going to walk through it and show
you some bugs in it.
Then I want to show you how we can comprehensively
address the root causes of those issues.
Then I'll get into some of the human factors
and how web standards can help us advance
security.
So, let me show you some code.
So, can you is this is this something that
people can see?
If this is too small, you might want to move
forward.
So, as you can see, this is a vanilla Node.js
server.
I'm requiring a bunch of modules up top.
The least popular of these modules has about
350,000 downloads per week.
So, these are not uncommon modules to see.
I'm setting some headers.
And, well, the Chrome people would be unhappy
with me if I showed Chrome XSS protection
bypasses.
So, I'm putting in XSS zero for demo purposes.
And then I've got a function that creates
a handler.
So, it does some session management.
Make sure there's a unique per client cookie.
And then we get into the bulk of the handler
function.
So, you can see here in the middle it's I've
defined the URL space.
We have slash, which is our index page.
Upload, which lets me upload a file.
Calculate, which calculates an expression.
And then we collect client errors.
So, let me show you how this works in practice.
So, the goal of this application is to let
people upload equations and then compute them
with results.
And so, I can choose XPY just as the text
X plus Y in it.
I upload that file.
It gives me something that I can share with
other users.
And I can type some JSON into the box here.
You see that I've got a radio button.
And if I can type a line of JSON without screwing
up.
I get one plus one is 42.
This isn't particularly surprising, but I
have to wonder what it all means.
So, we've got our URL space and then we get
into the handlers.
So, you can see when we're serving the index
page, we spit out a bunch of HTML.
And we spit out a form with our text area
and a radio button for each of our uploaded
files.
And at the bottom we have our upload form.
So, once we've got our equation, once once
a user tries to upload forms, I use multi
party to handle the upload.
For each file I multi party gives us a random
file name for each file.
It give uses a temporary file.
And we're calling out to the shell.
So, we see to the directory.
We create a directory for the current session
if one doesn't exist.
We move the temporary file into a shared path
which gives us which just has the same base
name as the temporary file.
That's an auto generated file name.
And then we link the shared file into the
current user's directory.
So, you're probably thinking, he's calling
out to the shell, this is a big security no
no.
This kind of thing happens in a lot of code
because the shell is so seductively simple.
This is a very succinct piece of code that
does something that will probably require
a dozen lines.
In addition, all of the inputs, FS route is
controlled by the application.
This directory is based on random numbers
generated by the application.
They're not controlled by an attacker.
The same for the rest of it.
The attacker controls none of this none of
the inputs to this.
Except as it turns out, the file extension
of the uploaded file.
So, this seems like a very incontroversial
use of something that's known to be a hazard.
And as it turns out, there is a subtle bug
in excuse me.
So, I can send a crafted input, if I don't
fall off the stage.
I can send a crafted input to the upload form.
And it has this file name.
And that works.
You can see that it's generated the crafted
upload here.
Based on this file extension.
That file extension is X.Y followed by an
obscure Unicode new line.
Followed by something which breaks out of
coded string.
Then it does touch, and then it continues
on with something.
It reopens the quote so that the whole form
is a valid shell string.
And if I look for the file, it's now sitting
in the root directory of my application.
So, what happened was we a very quite uncontroversial
use of the shell.
Due to an obscure bug in a in a third party
library.
One that has been fixed, by the way.
So, I'm not reporting zero days here.
An obscure bug in a third party library lets
me take offer the shell, get shell special
characters into where the user thought that
there were only going to be alphanumerics
from a randomly generated file name.
And so, we need to have more consistent ways
to address this problem.
And that's going to be a theme throughout
this talk.
So, moving on, when we calculate the result,
we lead the uploaded file, including the text,
plus one.
We parse some JSON.
When I showed you earlier, I showed you JSON
which said X was 1 and Y was 41.
And then we get we use a library that checks
that the uploaded file only contains arithmetic
operations.
And then the result of that is probably going
to be a number.
So, we output a string if everything is okay.
If there's an error message, we tell you there's
an error message.
We're careful to escape it.
If not, we don't.
There's a problem.
Arithmetic expressions in JavaScript sometimes
produce strings.
And so, that allows me to run arbitrary JavaScript.
If you didn't catch that, there was an alert
which popped up.
So, the payload is script alert, one script,
I ran that on the client.
So, again, the this is the kind of error,
you know, that occurs in a lot of, for example,
ad hock reporting software where you need
to report client side expressions.
It's an easy mistake to make.
You need a consistent way that the developer
has [audio breaking up] we need the best ways
to our security catching all of our different
client and, you know, on the server side we
also often want to figure out which one is
on the client.
So, log client error is a receiver for for
messages from the client on the client I don't
know if you can see this.
We keep patch console.error so that it not
only dumps things to the developer console,
it also phones home with error messages.
And this is intriguing style little zebra.
I don't know if you guys are familiar with
the colors module.
Let me just show you what this looks like
in practice.
So, let's try not to fall off this side either.
So, I did console that error, zebras are so
fun.
You see it shows up in the developer console.
And you can see down here, zebras are so fun.
And that happens because and the colors module
allows you to colorize your log output.
This is the kind of thing that, you know,
an intern comes into your project.
They decide, I'm having trouble trolling through
the logs to find what I'm going to do.
I'm going to make their logs a little bit
more awesome.
You know, zebras are so fun.
Rainbows are awesome.
And they're even more awesome when they're
in your log files.
So, an attacker can obviously Spam your logs
now.
But unless if you're going to accept telemetry
from the client at all, especially when the
client isn't in a consistent state, you need
to, you know, accept that and filter it later.
But there's another thing that an attacker
can do with this.
Because of another subtle flaw that has since
been fixed in the color package, I can upload
a file.
So, I'm going to upload helloworld.js.
It gives me this random string.
So, I'm going to say nuance equals that random
string rather than trying to type out an entire
tech.
So, this attack code you can see over here.
It does a post to client error, but with a
style that's equal to dot, dot, dot slash,
dot, dot slash uploads, slash not.
So, there is a subtle flaw in colors.js.
Colors, if the type of the theme is string,
then it requires a theme.
Which allows you to get an arbitrary string,
possibly attacker controlled, treated as a
module name.
So, you can see down here that the attacker
code ran, hello world, and then we've got
the generic message that the attacker sent.
So, we saw three different exploits.
We saw exploits in, you know, this is contrived
code that I've put together.
I wanted to put together, it's about 140 lines
of code that is vulnerable to three different
kinds of three different classes of vulnerabilities.
It is the kind of code that you might say
there's something dodgy going on in code review,
but hopefully if I've done my job, you can't
quite put your finger on why.
And yet it leave this is application wide
open.
What we didn't see was malicious code.
None of this code was written with the no
malicious code reached this until it was actually
running in production.
We saw that the developer tried to resist
attacks.
So, they put escape.HTML in almost all the
right places.
But not consistently.
We saw widely used dependencies.
We didn't see uncommon dependencies that have
probably not had enough eyeballs to catch
the errors.
And we saw the server side is still vulnerable.
And an npm audit, it's awesome, by the way,
if you haven't come across it.
Npm audit reports no problems with this code.
So, what we need is we need a way these are
the common kind of errors that developers
make.
What we need is a way to make sure that even
when developers make common errors that we're
not vulnerable.
So, I'm going to show you how to fix these
in what I hope are comprehensive ways.
The three problems.
The abuse of require via the our client logs
collection.
Shell injection when on a file upload.
And cross site scripting.
So, to fix access S, the first thing we do,
it's kind of ironic.
We get rid of our dependency on escape.HTML.
And we actually get rid of most of our code
that generates HTML and move it into templates.
So, here we're requiring generated files that
are compiled from templates.
So, all of this goes away.
And we end up calling response.end with a
call to a template.
That template is compiled from a pug file.
If you're not familiar with pug, it's a template
language.
It auto escapes content.
So, in the case of let me see.
I'm having a hard time reading this.
So, here is a dynamic expression.
The name of a radio button.
It includes radio and a number.
That will be automatically escaped.
In this case, the session will be automatically
HTML escaped.
So, this HTML escapes isn't perfect.
It Pug templates are still vulnerable to URLs,
I'm working on a plugin to fix that.
We have moved our HTML generation, generating
code, to something that is safe by default.
Users can opt out of escaping.
But security people like me can make scanners
that can find those kinds of problems.
What we then do is take the templates and
wrap them in a function, so the result is
a trusted HTML.
A trusted HTML creates a trusted HTML value
from a string.
We're using the type system.
Instead of just passing strings around, we
want to distinguish strings that we know are
safe from strings that we don't know where
they come from.
Then we monkey patch response.right and response.end.
And what this means is that if any plain old
string reaches response.end and response.right,
it won't get written.
You'll get an exception instead.
This kind of guides developers towards using
tools that produce trusted HTML.
And so, we've covered the two endpoints.
We've got our sources for creating trusted
HTML.
And we have our end point that only accepts
trusted HTML.
This is not perfect.
A malicious developer could probably work
around this by reaching into prototypes to
get at the underlying response.right.
But it's pretty good when you trust your developers
and work with them.
And then what we need to do is we want to
make sure we still have the problem.
What can create trusted HTML?
Well, it turns out, anybody.
Which means that the path for least resistance
for a developer is, I trust myself to make
trusted HTML.
So, I'll make trusted HTML.
There's some machinery in this augmentable
tine, a super type of trusted HTML.
There's some machinery in there which lets
us control who can create those values.
So, this appears in package.JSON.
It says we're granting the ability to create
trusted HTML to the following packages, trustedtemplate.js.
That's the file to wrap the pug templates.
There's one more to close the loop, but I'll
point that out later.
And then as an additional security measure,
we put in a pretty strict content security
policy.
So, if you guys are unfamiliar with the content
security policy error, it allows you to specify
what scripts can low.
It receives the header and says I will only
allow in this case scripts that have the source
CSP a nonce that is this CSP nonce value.
That value is defined up there as a random
string that is scoped to the session.
So, every sorry, scoped to the response.
So, every response has a different CSP nonce.
So, that means that only script tags that
are marked that way will run.
And then if there are any violations, they
get reported and that show up in our logs.
And in our pug template we mark our script
tag with the CSP nonce so that our form validation
code runs.
And so, we crafted a solution from save by
default tools, pug, auto escapes, unless you
opt out.
And we can control those opt out.
It distinguishes safe from unsafe values for
particular context.
In this case, the HTML that is allowed to
be a part of a response body.
We checked the safety at run time.
So, we guarded our response writer.
Response.write doesn't take strings, only
trusted HTML.
And we grant privilege the ability to make
trusted values are stored in source control
and they're checked at run time.
So, static linters like ESLint and TSLint,
they can catch it, but they are unsound.
And
on to the next vulnerability.
You saw this code already.
We were granting trusted HTML to trusted template.
We also granted the ability to create to SH
template tag the ability to create something
called SH fragment.
And that's going to figure in our solution
to shell injection.
It looks like I am running out of time, so
maybe I should move forward.
Okay.
So, what we end up doing is we end up replacing
our callout to the child process with the
use of the SH template tag.
And SH template tag is like pug.
It auto escapes.
It auto escapes for the SH and bash grammars.
We use similar mechanisms to make sure that
only SH fragments can reach child process.
And that involves hooking into require so
that, for example, the only thing that can
require child process is the exec SH fragment.
If anything else tries to, we block it.
And then quickly, we can also use these require
hooks to do things like figure out what are
all the production sources?
So, I instrumented them with the test runner.
After the tests run I walked the module graph
starting at the main module.
Here is the main module.
The gray modules sorry if this is entirely
unreadable.
The gray modules are all things under known
modules.
And the white modules are the actual source
code.
What we ended up with is we found 58 JavaScript
files were needed out of the 114 installed
when only = prod are available under the Node
modules.
We can hash those, and we can make sure that
the block any requires of files that have
unrecognized hashes.
So, this solves or problem with the colors
module.
And so, crafting strong security stories,
having secured by design tools is useful is
great but they're only useful if people use
them.
We can run our test code to establish a baseline
before code becomes available and open to
attack.
We can use lightweight dynamic enforcement
which actually solves the security problems.
And if done right, it guides developers towards
these safe by design tools.
And module linking hooks let us close a loop
and make guarantees about only these modules
would result in these kinds of security vulnerabilities.
Therefore, we can security people like me
can focus our attention on those particular
modules.
So, security's a team effort.
With these techniques a team can opt into
security processes.
They can record human judgments and source
control about which modules they trust to
do what.
And they can enforce those judgments dynamically.
And I have lots of awesome froes diagrams,
but if you guys are interested in standards,
here are four standards to keep an eye on
that I think will help us with security.
The realm standard.
That gives privilege separation within a Node
namespace and provides the kind of import
hooks that I think are useful.
Trusted types provides libraries for strings
that are not just strings.
Strings that we trust to specify HTML or script
or URLs we might load into an origin.
Module keys allows us to represent the identity
of a module in a way that's not spoofable.
And decorators are not directly security relevant,
but they provide things like annotations in
other languages which can improve the ergonomics
of a lot of this.
And you can get the note security roadmap
at that URL at the top.
The code for that I demoed is at that GitHub
URL.
Here are some of the some of the standards
that I talked about.
And if you like web security, I put together
a series much web security puzzles.
And you can find me on Twitter @michaelsamuel.
Thank you for being an awesome audience.